Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Thursday, July 19, 1990, Florida resident Steve McGowan received a letter in the mail from his 34-year-old sister, Beverly. The siblings had last spoken on Sunday, July 15, when Steve called Beverly to see if she would like to drop by for a visit.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1990年7月19日星期四，住在佛罗里达州的史蒂夫·麦高恩（Steve McGowan）收到了一封寄给他的信，寄信人是他34岁的妹妹贝弗利（Beverly）。兄妹俩最后一次通话是在7月15日星期日，当时史蒂夫打电话给贝弗利，问她愿不愿意过来串门。
Beverly had declined, saying that she was too busy. Their conversation was pleasant and ordinary. Now, four days later, Steve was mildly surprised to find Beverly had sent him a letter out of the blue. The brief note contained the following message. I just want to say goodbye to you and the kids and let you know that what I am doing is the right thing. This is what I need at this point in my life, so don't worry.
贝弗利拒绝了，说她太忙了。他们的对话愉快而寻常。然而四天后，史蒂夫有些惊讶地发现贝弗利竟然无缘无故地给他写了一封信。这封简短的信里写着以下内容：我只想向你和孩子们道别，并让你知道我正在做的事情是正确的。这是我现阶段生活中所需要的，所以不用担心。
When I come back, I will be a much better and happier person. Beverly was the youngest of the three McGowan children. The family hailed from Philadelphia, but had all relocated to Florida a little over a decade earlier. Beverly lived on the coast in Pompano Beach. Her sister Jane lived 11 miles north in Boca Raton. Steve resided in central Florida. Like her brother, Jane also received a cryptic farewell letter from Beverly.
当我回来时，我会成为一个更好、更快乐的人。贝弗利是麦高恩家三个孩子中最小的一个。这家人原本来自费城，但在十多年前都搬到了佛罗里达州。贝弗利住在海岸边的庞帕诺比奇。她的姐姐简住在北面11英里外的博卡拉顿。史蒂夫则住在佛罗里达州中部。和她的哥哥一样，简也收到了贝弗利发来的神秘告别信。
It detailed her decision to make some big life changes in order to go traveling. She wrote of quitting her job and selling her condo as she had to leave right away. The letters made little sense to Steve and Jane. After working hard for a long time, Beverly finally seemed happy with both her career and home life. She had recently purchased the condo and was working two jobs to pay off the mortgage. They couldn't understand why she would suddenly give up everything and leave without a proper goodbye.
信中详细说明了她为了去旅行而做出改变人生的重大决定的经过。她写道自己辞去了工作，卖掉了公寓，因为她必须马上离开。这封信对史蒂夫和简来说有些莫名其妙。在辛苦工作了很长时间后，贝弗利似乎终于对自己的职业和家庭生活感到满意了。她最近刚买下这套公寓，并打两份工来偿还房贷。他们无法理解她为什么会突然放弃一切，甚至连一句像样的道别都没有就离开了。
The letters were written in Beverly's handwriting from a notepad she kept in her home. Both were postmarked Wednesday, July 18 and were sent from the city of Miami, about 37 miles south of Pompano Beach. When calls to Beverly's home phone failed to connect, Jane visited a police station to report her missing. There was little they could do, as the letters indicated that Beverly had left of her own accord. That night, Steve and Jane headed to Pompano Beach to investigate the matter for themselves.
信是用贝弗利的笔迹写在家里的一本记事本上的。两封信的邮戳都是7月18日星期三，从距离庞帕诺比奇以南约37英里的迈阿密市寄出。在拨打贝弗利家里的电话无人接听后，简前往警察局报案称其失踪。警方对此无能为力，因为信件表明贝弗利是自愿离开的。那天晚上，史蒂夫和简前往庞帕诺比奇亲自调查此事。
They arrived at Beverly's home, an upper-level apartment in a two-story condominium building. It was one of many similarly designed complexes that lined South Flagler Avenue. The long, quiet street was situated on the cusp of a dense neighborhood. Beverly's condo was compact. It featured two bedrooms and a balcony that overlooked the residence car park. Upon arrival, Steve and Jane noticed Beverly's red Volkswagen Fox wasn't in its usual parking spot. She wasn't home, but it didn't appear as though she had packed up and left for good.
他们来到了贝弗利家，这是一栋两层共管公寓楼的上层公寓。它是南弗拉格勒大道旁众多设计相似的住宅区之一。这条长而安静的街道位于一个密集居民区的边缘。贝弗利的公寓很紧凑。它有两间卧室和一个俯瞰住宅停车场的阳台。到达后，史蒂夫和简发现贝弗利的红色大众福克斯汽车并不在它通常的停车位上。她不在家，但看起来并不像是已经收拾好行李永久离开的样子。
There were dirty dishes in the kitchen sink, a nightgown had been left on her unmade bed, clothes were in the closet and strewn on the floor. Although there were also signs indicating that Beverly had no intention of returning, the telephone had been disconnected, the answering machine kept alongside it was gone, and there was no trace of Beverly's two pet cats. Steve and Jane rummaged through some drawers and discovered Beverly's address book, passport, and birth certificate were also missing. Steve contacted Beverly's employer at Glendale Federal Bank to see whether they could shed
厨房水槽里有脏盘子，未整理的床上留有一件睡袍，衣柜里和地板上散落着衣服。尽管也有迹象表明贝弗利无意返回：家里的座机电话已被拔掉，与之放在一起的答录机不见了，而且贝弗利养的两只宠物猫也踪迹全无。史蒂夫和简翻找了一些抽屉，发现贝弗利的通讯录、护照和出生证明也都不见了。史蒂夫联系了贝弗利在格伦代尔联邦银行的雇主，看看他们能否提供
any light on the situation. Beverly worked Monday to Friday in the bank's loans department, but also had a second part-time job at Goodwill, a non-profit organization. Steve was told that Beverly called in sick on Wednesday, July 18, the day before he received her goodbye letter. This was unusual, given Beverly's reputation as a responsible and reliable employee. During the call, she had also asked to speak to someone in the bank's mortgage department. After she was transferred through, Beverly said she no longer wanted her condo and requested
任何关于现状的线索。贝弗利周一到周五在银行的贷款部门工作，但同时还在非营利组织“好市好”（Goodwill）做第二份兼职。史蒂夫被告知，贝弗利在7月18日星期三请了病假，也就是他收到她告别信的前一天。鉴于贝弗利一向是个负责任且可靠的员工，这很不寻常。在通话期间，她还要求与银行抵押贷款部门的人通话。转接后，贝弗利说她不再想要她的公寓，并要求
to foreclose on it. She was told that she would have to send a telegram to verify her request. A telegram was subsequently received. It also gave the bank permission to dispose of the personal belongings left in her home. Although the circumstances were strange, Steve began to believe that his sister had just left without a proper explanation. He lodged a missing persons report with the local authorities and also had Beverly's credit cards cancelled.
对其实施止赎。她被告知必须发送一封电报来确认她的请求。随后银行收到了一封电报。电报还授权银行处理她家中留下的个人物品。尽管情况诡异，史蒂夫还是开始相信他的妹妹只是没有留下合理的解释就离开了。他在当地警局报了人口失踪，并挂失了贝弗利的信用卡。
He hoped that cancelling the cards would hinder her travel plans and make her angry enough to reach out to her family. On the evening of Thursday, July 19, 31-year-old Jesse Moorhead and his niece went out to catch bait for bass fishing. They arrived at a wide irrigation canal located 100 miles north of Pompano Beach in a remote area of St. Lucie County. The canal is reached via a dirt track and is bordered by an unkempt grassy embankment. One side of the waterway empties out into the St. Lucie River estuary.
他希望挂失信用卡能阻碍她的旅行计划，并让她气得主动与家人联系。7月19日星期星期四晚上，31岁的杰西·穆尔黑德（Jesse Moorhead）和他的侄女外出捕捉用于垂钓鲈鱼的鱼饵。他们来到了位于庞帕诺比奇以北100英里的圣露西亚县偏远地区的一条宽阔灌溉运河旁。这条运河通过一条泥路到达，周围环绕着无人修剪的草堤。水路的另一端汇入圣露西亚河口。
The other leads south to the state's sprawling tropical wetlands, the Florida River Glades. Just after 7pm, Jesse was walking alongside the canal while his niece waited nearby in his car. On the embankment, he spotted what appeared to be a bag of rags and went over to inspect them. Upon realizing what he had actually discovered, Jesse raced back to his car and contacted the police. Investigators from St. Lucie County Sheriff's Department arrived at the canal and headed
另一端向南通往该州广阔的热带湿地——佛罗里达大沼泽地。刚过晚上7点，杰西沿着运河散步，他的侄女则在附近的汽车里等候。在路堤上，他发现了一个看起来像是一包破布的东西，于是走过去查看。意识到自己究竟发现了什么后，杰西飞奔回车里并报警。圣露西亚县警长办公室的调查人员赶到运河并前往
to the location described by Jesse. There, they found the mutilated remains of a female adult. She was dressed in jeans, a single white sandal and a pink floral shirt that was bunched up around her neck. She had been killed elsewhere before her body was dumped at the site. There was a gaping wound on her abdomen, though its cause was unclear. It could have been a deliberate injury or the result of post-mortem trauma to the body, as alligators populated the canal.
杰西描述的地点。在那里，他们发现了女性成人的残缺遗体。她穿着牛仔裤、一只白色凉鞋和一件卷在脖子周围的粉红色碎花衬衫。她在遗体被抛弃到现场之前就在别处被杀害了。她的腹部有一个巨大的伤口，尽管原因尚不清楚。这可能是蓄意伤害，也可能是遗体遭受死后创伤的结果，因为运河里栖息着短吻鳄。
The killer had gone to disturbing lengths to prevent the victim from being identified. Her hands had been removed and she had been crudely decapitated. The missing body parts were not found at the site. Despite this, a pivotal clue had seemingly gone unnoticed by the perpetrator. On the victim's right ankle, hidden under the cuff of her jeans, was a small tattoo of a yellow rose. A description of the tattoo was released to the local media and featured in news reports on the crime.
凶手费尽心机防止死者身份被识别。她的双手被砍掉，并被粗暴地斩首。失踪的身体部位在现场没有找到。尽管如此，凶手似乎还是遗漏了一个关键线索。死者的右脚踝上，藏在牛仔裤裤脚下方，有一个黄玫瑰的小纹身。该纹身的描述被发布给当地媒体，并在有关这起犯罪的新闻报道中播出。
Steve McGowan was at home when his telephone rang at around 10pm. On the other line was a friend of his missing sister, Beverly. She'd just heard the news of the woman's body found in St. Lucie County. The victim had a tattoo of a yellow rose on her right ankle, just like Beverly. The following day, Steve and Jane drove to St. Lucie County to speak with investigators. They provided a photograph of Beverly's rose tattoo, but declined to view the mutilated body as they found the prospect too distressing. The pair were nevertheless certain the woman was their sister.
大约晚上10点，史蒂夫·麦高恩正在家中，这时他的电话铃响了。电话那头是失踪妹妹贝弗利的一位朋友。她刚听到在圣露西亚县发现一具女尸的消息。死者的右脚踝上有一个黄玫瑰纹身，和贝弗利的一模一样。第二天，史蒂夫和简开车前往圣露西亚县与调查人员交谈。他们提供了一张贝弗利玫瑰纹身的照片，但拒绝查看残缺的尸体，因为他们觉得这个前景太令人痛心了。尽管如此，两人确信这个女人就是他们的妹妹。
They told investigators that Beverly had another tattoo just above her waistline of a rabbit from the animated Disney film, Bambi. This tattoo's location matched the victim's abdomen wound. It appeared as though the perpetrator had cut out the rabbit tattoo to hinder the identification process, but had missed the rose tattoo. The decapitation was also imperfect, as a portion of the victim's lower jaw still remained. A dental expert compared a tooth and filling from the remains to Beverly McGowan's dental records.
他们告诉调查人员，贝弗利在腰线上方还有另一个纹身，图案是迪斯尼动画电影《小鹿斑比》中的一只兔子。这个纹身的位置与受害者的腹部伤口相吻合。看起来凶手是为了阻碍辨认过程而切除了兔子纹身，却漏掉了玫瑰纹身。斩首也不完全彻底，因为受害者下巴的一部分仍然保留着。一名牙科专家将残骸中的一颗牙齿和补牙材料与贝弗利·麦高恩的牙科记录进行了比对。
Four days after Beverly's siblings received her goodbye letters, she was officially identified as the woman found by the St. Lucie County Irrigation Canal. A medical examiner struggled to establish a cause of death due to the severe mutilation. Beverly's abdomen tattoo had likely been cut out with a knife, while a chainsaw was used to remove her hands and head. It appeared as though her throat had been cut, but it couldn't be ruled with absolute certainty that this was what killed her. There was also a possibility that she had been bludgeoned or shot in the head.
在贝弗利的兄弟姐妹收到她的告别信四天后，她被正式确认为圣露西亚县灌溉运河边发现的女性。由于遗体残缺严重，法医很难确定死因。贝弗利的腹部纹身可能是用刀割掉的，而链锯则被用来切除她的双手和头部。看起来她的喉咙被割过，但无法绝对断定这就是致死原因。她也有可能被钝器殴打或头部中枪。
There was no evidence of sexual assault. The last time Beverly was seen alive was at work on Tuesday, July 17. She hadn't mentioned anything to colleagues about going away on a trip. That evening, she phoned a friend for a chat they had every Tuesday. The next day, her employers received the call from someone they believed to be Beverly, stating that she was unwell and wouldn't be coming in. An examination of Beverly's condo failed to uncover blood or any suspicious fingerprints, fibres, or hairs.
没有性侵的证据。贝弗利最后一次被看到活著是在7月17日星期二的工作中。她没有向同事提及任何要外出旅行的事。那天晚上，她给一个朋友打电话聊天，这是她们每周二都有的习惯。第二天，她的雇主接到一个他们认为是贝弗利的人打来的电话，称她身体不舒服，不会来上班了。对贝弗利公寓的检查没有发现血迹或任何可疑的指纹、纤维或毛发。
There was no sign of a struggle having taken place. The farewell letters to her family were puzzling, as they were in Beverly's handwriting. There was no sign that they had been coerced, yet they ended with the words goodbye, Bev. Her siblings said that Beverly would typically sign off letters by simply writing her name. They had no explanation as to who would harm Beverly or why. She was quiet, independent, and mostly kept to herself. She loved and doted on her nephews and they depended on her. She wasn't wealthy and she didn't have any problematic relationships.
没有发生过打斗的迹象。给她家人的告别信令人费解，因为它们是贝弗利的笔迹。没有迹象表明它们是被强迫写下的，然而信的结尾却是“再见，贝夫（Goodbye, Bev）”。她的兄弟姐妹说，贝弗利通常只会简单地签上自己的名字来结束信件。他们无法解释谁会伤害贝弗利，也不知道为什么。她安静、独立，大部分时间都独来独往。她爱她的侄子们并对他们百般呵护，而侄子们也依赖她。她并不富有，也没有任何有问题的恋爱关系。
Beverly's life had been marred by tragedy. Her first two boyfriends were killed in separate car accidents. She started dating again to move on, but would end relationships when they became serious. Steve later heard rumours of his sister exploring her sexuality during her early 30s. He described her as someone who travelled to the beat of a different drummer and believed she was only ever looking for love. Despite her traumatic past, Steve was clear that Beverly had recently been at her most content.
贝弗利的生活饱受悲剧摧残。她的前两个男友都在不同的车祸中丧生。为了走出阴影，她开始重新约会，但当关系变得严肃时，她总是会结束这段关系。史蒂夫后来听到传言说，他的妹妹在30岁出头时曾探索过自己的性取向。他形容她是一个特立独行的人，并相信她所寻求的始终只有爱。尽管有着痛苦的过去，但史蒂夫明确表示，贝弗利最近一段时间是她最满足的时候。
He did report one concerning incident. A week before Beverly disappeared, she told Steve about an unsettling message left on her answering machine. She didn't recognise the male caller's voice. She was recorded saying, I know where you live and I can't wait for us to be together. Troubled by the message, Beverly took her answering machine into work and played it to her colleagues. Curiously, the machine was missing from Beverly's abandoned condo.
他的确报告了一起令人担忧的事件。在贝弗利失踪前一周，她告诉史蒂夫答录机上留下一条令人不安的信息。她听不出这个男声是谁。录音里说：“我知道你住在哪里，我迫不及待地想让我们在一起。”被这条信息困扰的贝弗利把答录机带到单位放给同事听。奇怪的是，这个机器在贝弗利被遗弃的公寓里不见了。
Beverly valued her privacy, but working two jobs wasn't enough to pay off her mortgage. To supplement her income, she'd rented out her spare bedroom on two previous occasions. Neither roommate worked out in the long run. The first, a woman named Brenda, had clashed with Beverly over lifestyle differences. She was replaced by a man named George. She liked George, but he left after several months to get his own place. Both Brenda and George were questioned in relation to Beverly's murder, but were ruled out as suspects.
贝弗利很重视自己的隐私，但打两份工还不足以还清房贷。为了增加收入，她曾在前两次将多余的卧室出租。从长远来看，这两位室友都不合适。第一个室友是一个名叫布伦达（Brenda）的女人，她因生活方式的不同而与贝弗利产生冲突。她后来被一个叫乔治（George）的男人取代。她挺喜欢乔治，但他几个月后就搬出去找自己的地方了。布伦达和乔治都曾就贝弗利的谋杀案接受盘问，但都被排除在嫌疑人之外。
Investigators also spoke with a painter named Mike who lived in Beverly's apartment complex. The pair had struck up a close friendship and caught up for dinner several nights a week. Mike was adamant that he would never harm Beverly. He said he was out of town at the time of the murder, preparing for a gallery exhibition. His alibi checked out, and Mike too was ruled out. He said he had spoken to Beverly two days before she disappeared. Mike called to ask if she wanted to have dinner with him that night. Beverly typically accepted spontaneous plans, but not on this occasion.
调查人员还与一名住在贝弗利公寓大楼里名叫迈克（Mike）的油漆工交谈。两人建立了亲密的友谊，每周有几个晚上聚在一起吃晚餐。迈克坚称他绝不会伤害贝弗利。他说谋杀发生时他不在镇上，正在为画廊展览做准备。他的不在场证明得到了核实，迈克也被排除嫌疑。他说他在贝弗利失踪前两天和她说过话。迈克打电话问她那天晚上愿不愿意和他一起吃晚餐。贝弗利通常会接受突如其来的计划，但这次没有。
She rejected Mike's offer, explaining that she was going to spend a time with a potential new roommate named Dallas. In early July, Beverly told several acquaintances that she'd placed an advertisement for a new roommate in the Fort Lauderdale Sun Sentinel newspaper. Applications came through, and Beverly interviewed several candidates in the week prior to her murder. When searching her home, investigators found a notepad with a list of applicants' details. Each entry featured a full name, a phone number, and an appointment time to view the condo.
她拒绝了迈克的邀请，解释说她要和一位潜在的新室友达拉斯（Dallas）共度时光。在7月初，贝弗利告诉几位熟人，她在《劳德代尔堡太阳哨兵报》上登广告招租新室友。申请接踵而至，贝弗利在谋杀案发生前的一周面试了几个候选人。在搜查她的家时，调查人员发现了一个记事本，上面列有申请人的详细信息。每个条目都包含全名、电话号码以及查看公寓的预约时间。
There was one exception. One entry only included a first name. She read, Alice, Tuesday, 6.30. After meeting Alice, Beverly spoke about her enthusiastically to others. She was from London, was well-dressed, drove an impressive car, and worked for the multinational technology company IBM. Alice was moving to the area because she had been placed on temporary work duty at the company's Fort Lauderdale office.
有一个例外。有一个条目只包含一个名字。上面写着：“爱丽丝，周二，6点半。”在见过爱丽丝后，贝弗利满腔热情地向其他人谈起她。她来自伦敦，衣着考气，开着一辆令人印象深刻的车，并且在跨国科技公司IBM工作。爱丽丝之所以搬到这个地区，是因为她被派往该公司劳德代尔堡办公室进行临时工作。
Beverly chose Alice as her new roommate. She told a friend that Alice was moving in around Friday, July 20. Beverly's brother, Steve, also knew about Alice. Although he hadn't met her, Beverly reassured him that she was trustworthy. Beverly was not the type to be suspicious of others and gave everyone she met the benefit of the doubt. Beverly also mentioned that Alice had introduced her to numerology. Followers of this belief assign numerical values to letters, names, and birth dates.
贝弗利选择了爱丽丝作为她的新室友。她告诉一位朋友，爱丽丝将在7月20日星期五左右搬进来。贝弗利的哥哥史蒂夫也知道爱丽丝的事。虽然他没见过她，但贝弗利向他保证她是值得信赖的。贝弗利不是那种对别人起疑心的人，对遇到的每个人都给予充分的信任。贝弗利还提到，爱丽丝向她介绍了命理学。这种信仰的追随者会将数字赋予字母、名字和出生日期。
They used these values to calculate when certain events might occur for an individual. Alice offered to predict Beverly's future using numerology and created a rudimentary chart for her. To complete it, Alice required various numbers significant to Beverly's life. Beverly reportedly supplied them. They included her birth date, as well as her social security, passport, and driver's license numbers. Alice ascertained that Beverly would meet a man she would marry at the age of 40 and
他们用这些数值来计算个人某些事件可能发生的时间。爱丽丝主动提出用命理学预测贝弗利的未来，并为她制作了一张粗略的图表。为了完成它，爱丽丝需要贝弗利生活中各种重要的数字。据报道，贝弗利提供了这些数字。其中包括她的出生日期，以及她的社保、护照和驾照号码。爱丽丝断定贝弗利将在40岁时遇到一个她将要嫁给的男人，
would come in to great wealth. She also provided a warning. There was a man and a woman in Beverly's life who were going to deceive and hurt her. Overall, Beverly was pleased by Alice's predictions and shared them with some of her friends. Alice's full identity remained a mystery. Beverly hadn't kept note of anything other than her first name. Furthermore, there was no evidence indicating that Alice had moved in or even visited Beverly's condo.
并且会发大财。她还提供了一个警告。贝弗利的生活中有一个男人和一个女人会欺骗和伤害她。总的来说，贝弗利对爱丽丝的预测很满意，并与一些朋友分享了这些预测。爱丽丝的真实身份仍然是个谜。贝弗利除了她的名字之外没有记录任何东西。此外，没有证据表明爱丽丝曾搬进或甚至去过贝弗利的公寓。
Investigators reached out to YPM and were told that the company had no English employees working in the South Florida area. They didn't even have an office in Fort Lauderdale. Examination of Beverly's financial statements revealed that on the same day her body was found, someone withdrew $795 from the $800 in her bank account. Her visa credit card was then used 22 miles from her home to purchase women's clothing and books from the upscale Aventura Mall in Miami. The retail assistants who served the customer using Beverly's card described her as a striking
调查人员联系了IBM，被告知该公司没有英国员工在南佛罗里达地区工作。他们在劳德代尔堡甚至没有办公室。对贝弗利财务报表的检查显示，在她尸体被发现的同一天，有人从她银行账户的800美元中取走了795美元。接着，她的Visa信用卡在距离她家22英里外的迈阿密高档阿文图拉购物中心（Aventura Mall）被用来购买女装和书籍。使用贝弗利卡的服务员将这位顾客描述为一个引人注目的
blonde woman with an English accent. The description conjured images of a tall blonde woman who was currently at the center of a national media spectacle. Eight years earlier in 1982, Laurie Bembenik was sentenced to life in prison for the shooting murder of her husband's ex-wife. The dramatic case became a tabloid sensation. Bembenik's glamorous appearance and status as a former model made her something of a celebrity.
金发碧眼、带有英国口音的女人。这个描述让人联想到一个身材高大的金发女子，她目前正处于全国媒体关注的中心。八年前的1982年，劳里·本贝尼克（Laurie Bembenik）因枪杀丈夫的前妻被判处无期徒刑。这起戏剧性的案件轰动了小报。本贝尼克迷人的外表和前模特身份使她成为了某种名流。
Years before Beverly McGowan was killed, Bembenik had escaped her Wisconsin-based prison. When shown a photograph of Laurie Bembenik, the retail assistants at Aventura Mall identified her as the woman who had shopped using Beverly's credit card. But theories that Beverly might have crossed paths with the convicted killer were soon dashed. Bembenik had actually fled North to Canada. She was not in Florida at the time of Beverly's murder. The identification of Bembenik at Aventura Mall was declared a mistake and the lead dismissed.
在贝弗利·麦高恩被杀几年前，本贝尼克已经从她位于威斯康星州的监狱越狱。当被出示劳里·本贝尼克的照片时，阿文图拉购物中心的零售店员认出她就是使用贝弗利信用卡购物的那个女人。但认为贝弗利可能与这名被定罪的杀手有过交集的理论很快破灭了。本贝尼克实际上已经向北逃往加拿大。贝弗利遇害时她并不在佛罗里达。阿文图拉购物中心对本贝尼克的辨认被宣布为错误，这条线索也被驳回。
On Friday, July 20, the day after Beverly's body was found, her credit card was used again in Miami, this time at a travel agency called Thunderbird Travel. The card's holder appeared to be a man dressed as a woman. They wore oval-shaped eyeglasses and a cheap-looking short black wig with a fringe, described as a Cleopatra-style cut. They spoke with an English accent and introduced themselves as Sam. Apparently, Sam claimed to be headed to London in two days' time on British Airways Flight 292 and used Beverly's credit card to buy an Avis car hire voucher for Heathrow Airport.
7月20日星期五，即贝弗利遗体被发现的第二天，她的信用卡在迈阿密再次被使用，这一次是在一家名为“雷鸟旅游”（Thunderbird Travel）的旅行社。持卡人看起来像是一个女扮男装的男人。他们戴着椭圆形眼镜和一顶看起来很廉价的短黑假发，带有刘海，被形容为埃及艳后式的发型。他们操着英国口音，自称是萨姆（Sam）。显然，萨姆声称要在两天后乘坐英国航空公司292航班前往伦敦，并用贝弗利的信用卡购买了一张前往希思罗机场的赫兹（Avis）租车代金券。
Records from Beverly's home phone number revealed that someone had called Avis' Heathrow office the day before the voucher was purchased. Investigators were unsure whether this Sam person was the blonde suspect's accomplice or the same person wearing a disguise. Then there was Alice, Beverly's mysterious roommate. It was believed she had played a role in the plot. Her numerology exercise was thought to be a scam to obtain Beverly's personal details and steal her identity.
来自贝弗利家里的电话记录显示，有人在购买代金券的前一天给Avis的希思罗办公室打过电话。调查人员不确定这个叫萨姆的人是金发嫌疑人的同伙还是伪装的同一个人。然后是爱丽丝，贝弗利神秘的室友。人们认为她在阴谋中扮演了角色。她的命理学测试被认为是一个获取贝弗利个人详细信息并盗取其身份的骗局。
This theory was supported by the killer's efforts to prevent Beverly's body from being identified. Sam, the wig-wearing man in possession of Beverly's credit cards, had said he was flying to London on July 22. If he had caught the flight, then he'd already escaped overseas by the time investigators uncovered his involvement in the crime. Sergeant Dave Brooks of the St. Lucie County Sheriff's Department later described the rapid pace at which the bizarre investigation unraveled. He said it felt as though police were just a step or two behind the killers.
凶手为防止贝弗利尸体被辨认而做出的种种努力印证了这一理论。持有贝弗利信用卡的假发男萨姆曾说他将于7月22日飞往伦敦。如果他赶上了那趟航班，那么当调查人员发现他参与这起犯罪时，他已经逃到了海外。圣露西亚县警长办公室的戴夫·布鲁克斯（Dave Brooks）中士后来描述了这起离奇调查迅速发展的节奏。他说，感觉警方总是比凶手落后一两步。
Detectives pursuing the Sam lead obtained passenger logs from British Airways Flight 292 as well as other flights en route to Heathrow on July 22. Beverly McGowan's name wasn't listed on any, confirming Sam hadn't used her passport to board. A search of the surrounding area led to the discovery of Beverly's red Volkswagen Fox in the parking lot of a nearby motel. It had been there for five days. Fingerprint powder failed to uncover anything worthwhile, but four hairs from a synthetic
追查萨姆线索的侦探获取了英国航空292航班以及7月22日其他飞往希思罗航班的乘客名单。贝弗利·麦高恩的名字没有出现在任何名单上，这证实了萨姆没有用她的护照登机。对周边地区的搜寻导致在附近一家汽车旅馆的停车场发现了贝弗利红色的福克斯大众汽车。它在那里停了五天。指纹粉末没有发现任何有价值的东西，但在车里发现了四根人造
black wig were found inside. British Airways Flight 292 arrived at Heathrow Airport on Monday, July 23, London time. After the plane landed, a passenger with short black hair and oval-shaped eyeglasses approached the Avis Hire Car service counter. They had reserved a car under the name Beverly McGowan and handed over Beverly's driver's license to confirm the booking. Beverly had dark, shoulder-length hair and wore glasses. The person standing at the desk looked like her.
黑色假发的头发。英国航空292航班于伦敦时间7月23日星期一抵达希思罗机场。飞机降落后，一名留着短黑发、戴着椭圆形眼镜的乘客走到了Avis租车服务柜台。他们以贝弗利·麦高恩的名字预订了一辆车，并交出贝弗利的驾照以确认预订。贝弗利留着深色齐肩发，戴着眼镜。站在柜台前的人看起来很像她。
The Avis Clerk requested a credit card to pay for a fuel deposit on the vehicle. The customer handed over Beverly's visa, but the payment failed and the card was declined. She explained that she must have overextended her limit and paid for the deposit with cash instead. In actuality, Steve McGowan had cancelled Beverly's credit card by this point. By the time detectives in Florida learned of this failed transaction, the customer pretending to be Beverly was long gone. As the credit card was no longer functional, its transactions couldn't be used to track
Avis职员要求提供一张信用卡来支付车辆的燃油押金。顾客交出了贝弗利的Visa卡，但支付失败，卡被拒绝了。她解释说自己一定透支了额度，转而用现金支付了押金。事实上，史蒂夫·麦高恩此时已经挂失了贝弗利的信用卡。当佛罗里达州的侦探得知这笔失败的交易时，冒充贝弗利的顾客早已逃之夭夭。由于信用卡已无法使用，其交易记录已无法用于追踪
them. Investigators were certain that the customer was the suspect from the Miami travel agency going by the name Sam. Though, there were discrepancies between witness reports as to whether Sam was a man or woman. Sam's arrival in the UK meant they were out of the jurisdiction of American law enforcement. The Florida detectives phoned the London Metropolitan Police's Criminal Investigation Department for help. Detective John Cornish agreed to assist with the foreign investigation.
他们。调查人员确信，这位顾客就是迈阿密旅行社那个名叫萨姆的嫌疑人。不过，目击者关于萨姆是男是女的报告存在差异。萨姆抵达英国意味着他们超出了美国执法部门的管辖范围。佛罗里达的侦探打电话给伦敦警察厅的刑事调查部寻求帮助。约翰·康宁汉姆（John Cornish）警探同意协助进行涉外调查。
He spoke with Avis and ordered staff to direct the suspect to their nearest office should they get in contact. Police would then be dispatched to the location to await their arrival. Later that week, Sam contacted Avis. They requested to extend their lease and were told to visit a nearby Avis office. Police staked out the location, but Sam never showed. A backup plan was devised, wherein officers would lie in wait at Heathrow Airport on the date the car was due to be returned.
他与Avis交谈，并下令员工如果与嫌疑人取得联系，应将其引导至最近的办公室。随后警方将被派往该地点等待其到达。那周晚些时候，萨姆联系了Avis。他们要求延长租期，并被告知去附近的Avis办公室。警方埋伏在该地点，但萨姆从未露面。制定了一个备用计划，即在汽车归还日期当天，警员将在希思罗机场埋伏等待。
The day arrived and Metropolitan Police waited in position. Once again, Sam didn't appear. Around mid-morning, Sam's hire car was discovered abandoned several miles away from the airport. It had been wiped of fingerprints. The police realized they were dealing with a criminal who knew exactly what they were doing. Suspecting that Sam was fleeing back to the States, Detective Cornish ordered his team to board every America-bound flight that day to inspect the passengers.
日子到了，伦敦警察厅的警员们就位等待。萨姆再次没有出现。接近上午中期时，萨姆租的汽车被发现在距离机场几英里远的地方被遗弃。车上的指纹已被擦拭干净。警方意识到他们面对的是一个完全知道自己在做什么的罪犯。怀疑萨姆正逃回美国，康宁汉姆警探下令他的团队登上当天每一架开往美国的航班检查乘客。
No one matching Sam's description was cited. They had lost their only lead. Little progress was made in the case over the following year. On November 13, 1991, Beverly Story was featured on an episode of the NBC television program Unsolved Mysteries. Steve McGowan appeared on camera and made a personal appeal for information. The Unsolved case was taking its toll on everyone involved. Sergeant Dave Brooks had been investigating Beverly's murder from the outset.
没有发现任何符合萨姆描述的人。他们失去了唯一的线索。在接下来的一年里，案件几乎没有取得什么进展。1991年11月13日，贝弗利·斯托里（Beverly Story）出现在NBC电视台节目《未解之谜》（Unsolved Mysteries）的一集中。史蒂夫·麦高恩出镜并呼吁大家提供信息。这个未解案件给所有相关人员都带来了沉重打击。戴夫·布鲁克斯中士从一开始就在调查贝弗利的谋杀案。
He went out of his way to keep Beverly's loved ones updated on the investigation's status, but was burdened by its roadblocks. One night, he visited Steve McGowan and broke down in tears. The languishing investigation was eventually scaled down. Some of those involved continued to look into the case whenever possible to try and develop new leads. The biggest clue to date was the passenger manifest from British Airways Flight 292, which left Miami on July 22, 1990, at 6.30pm.
他竭尽全力让贝弗利挚爱的人了解调查的最新进展，但却被其中的重重阻碍压得喘不过气来。一天晚上，他拜访了史蒂夫·麦高恩并失声痛哭。这项进展缓慢的调查最终被缩减规模。一些相关人员只要有可能就会继续调查此案，试图寻找新的线索。迄今为止最大的线索是英国航空292航班的乘客名单，该航班于1990年7月22日下午6:30离开迈阿密。
The suspect, known only as Sam, had not used Beverly's passport to board the flight, so must have booked a ticket under a different name. Investigators looked into the flight's 248 passengers, but ran into jurisdictional issues when examining individuals who did not reside in Florida. They sought assistance from the US State Department in Washington, DC to identify the non-Florida passengers. Every passenger name that couldn't be traced was submitted to be run through their system. They had to be compared with passport details, and the process would take years to complete.
仅被称为萨姆的嫌疑人没有使用贝弗利的护照登机，因此一定是化名订了票。调查人员查阅了该航班的248名乘客，但在审查不住在佛罗里达州的个人时遇到了管辖权问题。他们寻求华盛顿特区美国国务院的协助以识别非佛罗里达州乘客。所有无法追踪的乘客姓名都被提交并通过他们的系统进行比对。它们必须与护照详细信息进行比对，这个过程需要数年才能完成。
Five years after Beverly McGowan's murder, a Florida detective named Rena Craning Shield was assigned to the case. Beverly continued to look into the passenger manifest alongside Nora Pfeiffer, an investigator for the state's attorney. Nora had been involved in the case for years, and remained motivated to see it solved. In January 1996, the women received a name from the US State Department that they had identified as significant. Sylvia Ann Hodgkinson was a British citizen who occupied seat 18C on Flight 292.
在贝弗利·麦高恩谋杀案发生五年后，一位名叫雷娜·克拉宁·希尔德（Rena Craning Shield）的佛罗里达州女侦探被指派负责此案。贝弗利与州检察官调查员诺拉·菲弗（Nora Pfeiffer）一起继续调查乘客名单。诺拉参与此案多年，并且依然渴望看到它水落石出。1996年1月，两位女性从美国国务院得到了一个她们认定很重要的名字。西尔维娅·安·霍奇基森（Sylvia Ann Hodgkinson）是一名英国公民，占据了292航班的18C座位。
Her passport photo showed an adult woman with dark hair and eyebrows. Her birth date was listed as July 22, 1964. Sylvia's origins were traced to Lewisham, a borough in South-East London. Her beginnings were humble, and she had received very little education. She later married a dairy worker, but he passed away in 1985. Sylvia then lived in a shelter for women experiencing homelessness. Less than a year after her husband's death, a passport was issued in her name. Investigators suspected that someone else applied for the passport after stealing Sylvia's
她的护照照片显示一个留着深色头发和眉毛的成年女性。她的出生日期列为1964年7月22日。西尔维娅的根源可追溯到伦敦东南部的路易沙姆区。她的出身卑微，受过很少的教育。她后来嫁给了一名乳制品工人，但他于1985年去世。西尔维娅随后住在无家可归妇女收容所里。在她丈夫死后不到一年，一本以她的名义签发的护照被办了下来。调查人员怀疑有人在窃取西尔维娅的身份后申请了这本护照。
identity. As they were unable to find Sylvia's current whereabouts, they feared that she had been killed as well. The State Department determined that the alias Sylvia Hodgkinson was associated with two other names, Charlotte Ray Cowan and Elaine Antoinette Parent. The three identities were tied together following an incident that occurred almost one year after Beverly McGowan's murder. On Wednesday, May 22, 1991, police in North Miami approached a woman in a rental car.
由于无法找到西尔维娅目前的下落，他们担心她也遭到了杀害。国务院确定，西尔维娅·霍奇基森这个化名与另外两个名字相关：夏洛特·雷·科恩（Charlotte Ray Cowan）和伊莱恩·安托瓦内特·帕伦特（Elaine Antoinette Parent）。这三个身份在贝弗利·麦高恩谋杀案发生将近一年后发生的一起事件后被串联在了一起。1991年5月22日星期三，北迈阿密警方在租赁汽车中接近了一名女子。
The vehicle had been laced to more than six months earlier in Los Angeles, California. It was flagged as overdue for return, and was fixed with a stolen license plate to conceal its origins. The car's female occupant was a tall redhead. She identified herself as Charlotte Ray Cowan. She provided officers with official documentation to verify her identity. It was clear Charlotte had been sleeping in the car with her two dogs. There were several wigs in her possession, as well as a diary.
这辆车在半年多前于加利福尼亚州洛杉矶被转租。它被标记为逾期未还，并安装了盗窃的车牌来掩盖其来源。车上的女性乘客是一名高个子红发女郎。她自称是夏洛特·雷·科恩。她向警官提供了官方文件以核实身份。很明显，夏洛特和她的两只狗一直睡在车里。她身上有几顶假发以及一本日志。
She also carried multiple ID cards. They displayed her photograph but featured the names Sylvia Hodgkinson and Elaine Parent. Police took Charlotte into custody on the charge of failing to return a laced vehicle. She was held overnight and posted bail the following day. A court session was later held on the matter. One of the arresting officers was in attendance. When it came time for Charlotte Cowan to face the judge, a woman stood. She had short, straight red hair and was aged in her 30s.
她还随身携带多张身份证。它们显示着她的照片，但名字却是西尔维娅·霍奇基森和伊莱恩·帕伦特。警方以未能归还转租车辆的罪名将夏洛特拘留。她被拘留了一夜，并在第二天交了保释金。随后就此事举行了法庭听证会。其中一名抓捕警官出席了。当轮到夏洛特·科恩面对法官时，站起了一名女子。她留着短而直的红发，30多岁。
The arresting officer was stunned. The woman answering the summons was not the same person he had taken into custody. He immediately informed the judge. Charlotte was confused. She had received the summons to appear in court that day, but was not responsible for the crime it alleged she had committed. Charlotte asked the police officer if the person he had originally arrested for the offense was a tall redhead.
抓捕警官惊呆了。回答传唤的女人并不是他拘留的那个人。他立即通知了法官。夏洛特感到很困惑。她收到了那天出庭的传票，但她并没有犯下被指控的罪行。夏洛特问警官，他最初因该罪行逮捕的人是否是个高个子红发女郎。
When he replied yes, she said she knew exactly who it was. Almost a decade earlier, during the mid-80s, Charlotte Cowan was drinking at a bar in the city of Orlando. An immaculately dressed woman with an English accent approached her. She had short, straight red hair like Charlotte's and striking blue eyes. The woman introduced herself as Anne Tramont and offered to buy Charlotte a drink. Anne seemed too sophisticated for the bar they were in and Charlotte was surprised that she caught the attention of such a glamorous person.
当他回答“是”的时候，她说她知道那是谁。将近十年前的80年代中期，夏洛特·科恩正在奥兰多市的一家酒吧喝酒。一个衣着考究、带有英国口音的女人向她走来。她留着像夏洛特一样短而直的红发和一双引人注目的蓝眼睛。这个女人自我介绍叫安妮·特拉蒙特（Anne Tramont），并主动提出请夏洛特喝一杯。安妮看起来与他们所在的酒吧格格不入，夏洛特很惊讶自己会引起这样一个迷人人物的注意。
Nevertheless, she accepted the drink. The pair chatted and after a while, Anne raised the subject of numerology. She told Charlotte that she would love to create a numerology profile for her, then asked for Charlotte's birthday. Charlotte supplied the information. She also provided her time of birth, her social security number, and her driver's license details. Anne wrote everything down on a napkin and made positive predictions about Charlotte's
尽管如此，她还是接受了这杯酒。两人聊了起来，过了一会儿，安妮提出了命理学的话题。她告诉夏洛特她很乐意为她制作一个命理分析档案，然后询问夏洛特的生日。夏洛特提供了这些信息。她还提供了她的出生时间、社保号和驾照详情。安妮把一切都写在一张餐巾纸上，并对夏洛特的未来做出了积极的预测。
future. In an interview with British newspaper The Guardian, Charlotte later stated, She had the most sophisticated manner. She was so persuasive. Anne didn't talk about herself much. She did say she was mending a broken heart after a relationship with a former girlfriend ended badly. At one stage, a blonde-haired man entered the bar.
在接受英国《卫报》采访时，夏洛特后来表示：“她有着最精致的举止。她是如此具有说服力。安妮不怎么谈论自己。她的确说过她在抚平一段与前女友破裂的恋情带来的破碎心灵。”在某一时刻，一个金发男人走进酒吧。
Anne told Charlotte that he was her brother and said she had to go. Before leaving, she asked for Charlotte's phone number. Anne called the next day and the pair arranged to meet up for lunch. Charlotte's mother was present for the meal and was equally impressed by Anne. Several dates followed and Charlotte eventually met Anne's brother. He was as nicely dressed and well-mannered as his sister. Over time, contact between the women faded until they fell out of touch altogether. A couple of months later, Anne called Charlotte to say that her aunt died and had left her
安妮告诉夏洛特那是她的哥哥，并说她得走了。离开前，她要了夏洛特的电话号码。安妮第二天打了电话，两人安排一起吃午饭。夏洛特的母亲出席了这次聚餐，同样对安妮印象深刻。随后有了几次约会，夏洛特最终见到了安妮的哥哥。他像他姐姐一样衣着得体、举止文雅。随着时间的推移，两个女人之间的联系逐渐减少，直到最终完全失去联系。几个月后，安妮打电话给夏洛特，说她的姑姑去世了，留给她
a significant inheritance. Anne was required to split the money with her brother. She claimed that he'd had her committed to a mental health hospital so he could keep the entire amount. Approximately a month after this call, Anne appeared on Charlotte's doorstep at 3am. She was wearing a fake mustache, a wig, and a man's shirt and tie. Distraught and sobbing, Anne explained that she escaped from the hospital where her brother had her admitted.
了一笔相当可观的遗产。安妮必须把这笔钱和她哥哥平分。她声称他把她送进了一家精神病院，这样他就可以独吞这笔钱。大约在这通电话后一个月，安妮在凌晨3点出现在夏洛特的门廊上。她戴着假胡子、假发，穿着男式衬衫和领带。心烦意乱、泣不成声的安妮解释说，她从她哥哥把她关进去的医院逃了出来。
She was now on the run from her family and needed Charlotte's help to get away. Anne begged to borrow Charlotte's birth certificate so she could create a new identity for herself. Anne initially refused but relented when Anne grew increasingly distressed. Anne promised to return the certificate soon. Several weeks passed with no word from Anne. Charlotte began to worry. Then a letter arrived with her birth certificate enclosed and a note from Anne apologizing for the delay.
她现在正躲避家人的追捕，需要夏洛特的帮助才能逃跑。安妮恳求借用夏洛特的出生证明，以便她可以为自己创造一个新的身份。安妮起初拒绝了，但在安妮变得越来越痛苦时心软了。安妮承诺很快就会归还证明。几个星期过去了，没有任何安妮的消息。夏洛特开始担心。然后一封信送到了，里面附有她的出生证明以及安妮为延误道歉的便条。
Charlotte never heard from her again. A few years later, in mid-1991, Charlotte received a summons regarding a traffic violation in Miami. Baffled, she went to court to resolve the matter. It was quickly discovered that the error was due to the actual perpetrator stealing Charlotte's identity. Charlotte knew the person responsible was the woman she knew as Anne Tramont. Now that two of their suspect's identities were found to be stolen, investigators turned
夏洛特再也没有听到她的消息。几年后，即1991年中期，夏洛特收到了一张关于迈阿密交通违章的传票。一头雾水的她去法庭解决此事。很快人们发现，这个错误是由于真正的罪犯盗用了夏洛特的身份造成的。夏洛特知道负责人就是她所认识的安妮·特拉蒙特。既然嫌疑人的两个身份被发现是偷来的，调查人员便将注意力转向了
their attention to her third alias, Elaine Antoinette Parent. Like the others, Parent was a real person, though little could be found about her early life. She was born in the New York City borough of the Bronx on August 4, 1942. Her mother was French-Canadian while her father was American. The couple had no other children. By the time she was an adult, Elaine Parent was five foot seven inches tall with naturally dark hair and blue eyes.
她的第三个化名——伊莱恩·安托瓦内特·帕伦特。和之前的一样，帕伦特也是一个真实的人，尽管关于她早年生活的信息很少。她于1942年8月4日出生在纽约市布朗克斯区。她的母亲是法裔加拿大人，而父亲是美国人。这对夫妇没有其他孩子。到了成年时，伊莱恩·帕伦特身高五英尺七英寸，拥有天然的黑发和蓝眼睛。
Her weight varied between 140 and 150 pounds. At age 30, she relocated to Florida where she initially lived in an apartment in the village of Balharba. She later moved into a house in Dade County. For a time, Parent worked as a registered real estate agent. In 1976, Parent was arrested in Fort Lauderdale for shoplifting. As a result, her fingerprints were collected and stored on the police system. Then in 1985, she stole approximately $40,000 worth of jewelry from an elderly woman she
她的体重在140到150磅之间。30岁时，她搬到了佛罗里达州，最初住在巴尔港村的一间公寓里。她后来搬进了戴德县的一栋房子。有一段时间，帕伦特是一名注册房地产经纪人。1976年，帕伦特因入店行窃在劳德代尔堡被捕。因此，她的指纹被收集并存储在警察系统中。然后在1985年，她从一位老妇人那里偷走了价值约40,000美元的珠宝。
knew. This was around the same time Parent became acquainted with Charlotte Cowan. Parent's fingerprints were compared to those taken from the woman apprehended in 1991 for failing to return the hire car. They were a match. The woman pretending to be Charlotte Cowan was indeed Elaine Parent. She was released on bail, but never appeared for her day in court. There was nothing to indicate that Elaine Parent was a stolen identity like Sylvia Hodgkinson
知道了。大约在同一时期，帕伦特结识了夏洛特·考恩。帕伦特的手指纹与1991年因未归还租车而被捕的那名女性留下的指纹进行了比对。两者相符。那个假冒夏洛特·考恩的女子确实是伊莱恩·帕伦特。她被保释出狱，但此后再也没有在法庭上露面。没有任何迹象表明伊莱恩·帕伦特像西尔维娅·霍奇金森
and Charlotte Cowan. Investigators believed Parent was the true identity of the elusive suspect in the Beverly McGowan case, known previously as Sam. Parent's criminal history aligned with the circumstances leading up to Beverly's murder, the numerology scam, the stolen personal documents, and the use of a disguise. Yet, Beverly's case was the only known instance in which Parent had apparently killed the person whose identity she stole. Investigators were confident Parent was the woman named Dallas, who Beverly accepted
和夏洛特·考恩一样是个盗用身份的人。调查人员认为，帕伦特才是贝弗利·麦高恩案中那个此前被称为“山姆”的行踪诡秘的嫌疑人的真实身份。帕伦特的犯罪记录与贝弗利谋杀案发生前的种种情况相吻合，包括命理学骗局、被盗的个人文件以及伪装的使用。然而，贝弗利案是帕伦特唯一已知的、显然杀害了被她盗取身份之人的案件。调查人员确信，帕伦特就是贝弗利在死前几天接受的
as her roommate days before her death. But, they had yet to directly link Parent to Beverly's murder. The evidence in the McGowan case file was re-examined to find a connection to Parent. This included the farewell letters Beverly had sent her siblings. They were penned on a notepad from her condo. The handwriting was hers, and they didn't appear to have been written under duress. The decision was made to carry out forensic testing on the notepad itself. An electrostatic detection device, also known as Zesta, is a piece of equipment that can
室友达拉斯。但是，他们尚未将帕伦特与贝弗利的谋杀案直接联系起来。麦高恩案卷中的证据被重新审查，以寻找与帕伦特的联系。这包括贝弗利写给她兄弟姐妹的告别信。它们写在她公寓的记事本上。字迹是她本人的，而且看起来不像是被胁迫下写的。有关部门决定对记事本本身进行法医检测。静电检测仪，也被称为泽斯塔，是一种能够
reveal indentations in paper that may not be visible or legible to the human eye. These indentations are made when someone has written on another piece of paper that was previously on top of the paper being examined. Esther testing of Beverly's notepad revealed that it had been used to compose other pieces of writing. The hidden messages were painstakingly replicated, revealing handwriting that was not Beverly's. It appeared as though the author was writing to a woman whom she'd been in an intimate relationship with, but they had since parted.
显示纸张上凹痕的设备，这些凹痕可能是肉眼无法看到或辨认的。当有人在之前压在被检查纸张之上的另一张纸上写字时，就会留下这些凹痕。对贝弗利记事本的埃丝特检测显示，它曾被用来撰写其他文章。这些隐藏的信息被煞费苦心地复制出来，显示出并非贝弗利的字迹。看起来作者是在写信给一个她曾与其有过亲密关系、但后来已经分手的女性。
The messages were hostile in nature, with one excerpt reading, You will feel the repercussions, I guarantee it. After your treatment and abandonment of me, I have no remorse in tearing down what, in truth, I created anyways. Give me back my life. The letters were compared to samples of Elaine's parents handwriting, and they matched. A forensic psychologist named Dr Barbara Kerwin profiled parent for law enforcement. She later told the makers of the documentary The World's Most Wanted Woman that the letters
这些信件带有敌意，其中一段写道：“你会感到后果的，我向你保证。在你对我进行治疗并抛弃我之后，我毫不后悔去摧毁无论如何本来就是我创造的东西。把我的生活还给我。”这些信件与伊莱恩父母的字迹样本进行了比对，结果相符。一位名叫芭芭拉·克尔温博士的法医心理学家为执法部门对帕伦特进行了心理画像。她后来告诉纪录片《世界上头号通缉女性》的制作人，这些信件
were consistent with a rage-filled and highly manic psychiatric state. The letters parent wrote were addressed to a woman in London. She was the senior executive for an international blue-chip company. Upon this discovery, Detective John Cornish of the London Metropolitan Police rejoined the investigation. It had been about six years since Cornish had tracked the suspect, now known as Elaine Parent, after her arrival at Heathrow Airport. He had almost intercepted her, but she managed to evade his capture.
与充满愤怒且高度狂躁的精神状态相一致。帕伦特写的信是寄给伦敦的一位女性的。她是国际蓝筹公司的高级主管。发现这一情况后，伦敦警察厅的约翰·科尼什侦探重新加入了调查。距离科尼什追踪这位现在被称为伊莱恩·帕伦特的嫌疑人（在她抵达希思罗机场后）已经过去了大约六年。他差点就拦截了她，但她还是设法逃脱了他的抓捕。
Detective Cornish interviewed the woman parent had sent the scathing letter to. In order to protect her identity, she was given the pseudonym Witness X. Witness X said she'd met parent on a trip to Miami during the 1980s, and the pair had struck up a romantic relationship. In 1985, after parent was sought by police for stealing jewelry, she fled to London and moved in with Witness X. The couple's relationship soon deteriorated. Parent was prone to aggressive mood swings.
科尼什侦探对帕伦特发送那封尖刻信件的女性进行了采访。为了保护她的身份，她被赋予了化名“证人X”。证人X表示，她是在20世纪80年代的一次迈阿密之旅中遇到帕伦特的，两人擦出了浪漫的爱情火花。1985年，在帕伦特因涉嫌偷窃珠宝被警方通缉后，她逃往伦敦并搬去与证人X同住。这对伴侣的关系很快恶化。帕伦特容易出现攻击性的情绪波动。
She could quickly change from being calm and easygoing to violent and temperamental. She threatened Witness X's life and attempted to emotionally blackmail her. The couple broke up in 1990 and parent returned to the United States. To Witness X's surprise, parent returned to London a short while later, at the end of July. She was driving an Avis hire car. Parent persuaded Witness X to rekindle their relationship, but things quickly soured again. When they split for a second time, parent placed an advertisement in the Personals column
她可以迅速从平静随和变得暴力而反复无常。她威胁证人X的生命，并试图对她进行情感勒索。这对伴侣于1990年分手，帕伦特返回美国。令证人X惊讶的是，不久之后，即7月底，帕伦特又回到了伦敦。她开着一辆安飞士租车。帕伦特说服证人X重修旧好，但事情很快又恶化了。当他们第二次分手时，帕伦特在《伦敦》杂志的《Timeout》杂质的
of London's Time Out magazine. She wrote that she loved wine and was a gourmet cook who owned an excellent collection of copper cookware. Three months after returning to London, parent kidnapped Witness X's two dogs and flew back to the US. Back home, parent sent Witness X a death threat made of letters cut out from newspaper articles. She also tried to demand a ransom for Witness X's two dogs. These were believed to be the same dogs found in her possession when she was arrested in
“个人专栏”中登了一则广告。她写道，她热爱葡萄酒，是一位美食厨师，拥有极好的铜制炊具收藏。返回伦敦三个月后，帕伦特绑架了证人X的两只狗并飞回美国。回国后，帕伦特给证人X寄了一封由剪报上的字母拼凑而成的死亡威胁信。她还试图勒索证人X的两只狗的赎金。据信，这些就是1991年5月她在
Miami in May 1991. Witness X's information allowed investigators to fill in numerous gaps in parents' history. Investigators now understood that she must have met Sylvia Hodgkinson within her first year of living in London. Somehow, she managed to obtain enough information about Sylvia that she could take out a passport in her name. It was suspected that parent had stolen the identities of other vulnerable and unsuspecting persons.
迈阿密被捕时在她身上发现的同一批狗。证人X提供的信息使调查人员能够填补帕伦特历史上的许多空白。调查人员现在明白，她一定是在移居伦敦的第一年内就认识了西尔维娅·霍奇金森。不知何故，她设法获得了足够关于西尔维娅的信息，以至于能够以她的名义申领护照。人们怀疑帕伦特还盗取了其他脆弱且毫无戒心的个人的身份。
She had also learned to imitate a convincing English accent, allowing her to trick people into thinking she was British. By the end of 1996, Florida's State Department had filed charges of passport fraud against a lame parent. But they had no idea where she might be hiding. Her name was released to the media in an effort to generate leads, though investigators stopped short of naming her as a suspect in Beverly McGowan's murder. St. Lucie County Sheriff Bobby Niles told journalists.
她还学会了模仿令人信服的英国口音，这让她能够欺骗人们，让他们以为她是英国人。到1996年底，佛罗里达州国务院对伊莱恩·帕伦特提出了护照欺诈指控。但他们根本不知道她可能藏在哪里。她的名字被公之于众，以期搜集线索，不过调查人员并没有将她指认为贝弗利·麦高恩谋杀案的嫌疑人。圣卢西亚县警长鲍比·奈尔斯告诉记者：
The sheriff's office believes she may have vital information about the disappearance and the murder. She may even have first-hand knowledge. No viable tips emerged, but investigators were still managing to unravel parents' history. There was evidence that she had moved to the state of New Mexico in 1991 and worked there as a restaurant manager. Afterwards, she moved to Tennessee with a female friend and got a job at a Sears department store.
警长办公室认为她可能掌握着关于失踪和谋杀案的关键信息。她甚至可能掌握第一手资料。没有出现可行的线索，但调查人员仍在设法揭开帕伦特的历史。有证据表明，她在1991年搬到了新墨西哥州，并在那里做餐厅经理。之后，她和一个女性朋友搬到了田纳西州，并在西尔斯百货公司找到了一份工作。
The last confirmed sighting of parent took place around Easter in 1994. A former colleague from Sears spotted her on a road just south of Nashville. In 1998, the television program America's Most Wanted aired a segment about a lame parent. It was accompanied by a photograph of her with short black hair. She was dressed in a crisp white shirt and fine gold jewellery. A resident from the Florida City of St. Petersburg was watching television at home when the show aired. The moment she saw a lame parent's image, she immediately recognized her.
最后一次确认看到帕伦特是在1994年的复活节前后。西尔斯的一位前同事在纳什维尔以南的一条路上认出了她。1998年，电视节目《美国头号通缉犯》播出了关于伊莱恩·帕伦特的专题节目。节目中配有她留着黑色短发的照片。她穿着一件挺括的白衬衫，佩戴着精美的黄金首饰。佛罗里达州圣彼得斯堡市的一位居民在家看电视时播出了这个节目。一看到伊莱恩·帕伦特的照片，她就立刻认出了她。
Patricia Nevins was a church minister who knew parent as a bleached blonde by the name of Sandra Little. Although the woman shown on America's Most Wanted looked quite different to the person Patricia knew, she had the same chic sense of style. Patricia met a lame parent, masquerading as Sandra Little in 1992. Parent was destitute and living in a St. Petersburg shelter for people experiencing homelessness. The city of St. Petersburg is on the opposite side of the state from the Atlantic coast where parent had previously lived.
帕特里夏·内维斯是一名教堂牧师，她认识的帕伦特是个染成金发的女人，名字叫桑德拉·利尔。尽管《美国头号通缉犯》中出现的女人与帕特里夏认识的人看起来很不一样，但她有着同样别致的时尚品味。帕特里夏在1992年遇到了伪装成桑德拉·利尔的伊莱恩·帕伦特。帕伦特一贫如洗，住在圣彼得斯堡的一个流浪者收容所里。圣彼得斯堡市位于帕伦特以前住过的大西洋海岸的州另一侧。
Patricia offered to let parent stay in her spare bedroom and the pair lived together for almost a year and a half. During this time, parent, as Sandra Little, filed a civil negligence lawsuit against the state after she slipped in a restaurant and injured herself. She won and was awarded an undisclosed amount in damages. This evening's were spent watching both the local and international news. Once a week, she watched the latest episode of America's Most Wanted. Patricia described several peculiar incidents that occurred during her time living with
帕特里夏主动提出让帕伦特住在她的客房里，两人一起生活了近一年半。在此期间，帕伦特化名桑德拉·利尔，对州政府提起了一起民事疏忽诉讼，起因是她在一家餐厅滑倒受伤。她胜诉了，并获得了未公开金额的赔偿金。她的这些夜晚都是在看本地和国际新闻中度过的。一周一次，她会观看《美国头号通缉犯》的最新一集。帕特里夏向纪录片《世界上头号通缉女性》的制作人描述了她与
parent to the makers of the documentary, The World's Most Wanted Woman. Parent had once told her that the only way she could have a proper life would be if she had another identity. Then during a dinner party, parent mimed cutting off a guest's hand to obtain his gold bracelet. Patricia arranged for parent to speak with a psychiatrist. He later informed Patricia that parent was an extremely intelligent, budding sociopath who would leave Patricia's life as quickly as she arrived. This prediction came to pass when the two women parted ways in 1993.
帕伦特同住期间发生的几件奇怪的事情。帕伦特曾对她说，她能过上正常生活的唯一途径就是拥有另一个身份。然后在一次晚宴上，帕伦特模仿切断一个客人的手以获取他的金手镯。帕特里夏安排帕伦特与一位精神病医生交谈。他后来告诉帕特里夏，帕伦特是一个极其聪明、初露端倪的反社会者，她离开帕特里夏的生活会和她来时一样快。这个预测在1993年两名女子分道扬镳时应验了。
Five years later, Patricia saw a lame parent's photograph on America's Most Wanted. Following the television appeal, a strange letter was delivered to the St. Lucie County Sheriff's Office. This envelope bore a London post stamp and it contained a postcard. The image side featured a print copy of an oil painting. It depicted an older version of a lame parent. She was wearing a blue and green one-piece bathing suit and pearl earrings. Her hair was grey and styled in the same short, quaffed manner that parent often chose.
五年后，帕特里夏在《美国头号通缉犯》上看到了伊莱恩·帕伦特的照片。在这档电视呼吁播出后，圣卢西亚县警长办公室收到了一封奇怪的信。这个信封上盖着伦敦的邮戳，里面装着一张明信片。图片的一面是一幅油画的印刷复制品。它描绘了一个年老一些的伊莱恩·帕伦特。她穿着一件蓝绿色连体泳衣，戴着珍珠耳环。她的头发是灰色的，梳着帕伦特经常选择的同款短发蓬松发型。
She was shown climbing out of a swimming pool. The back of the card featured a typed message that read, Your Chameleon, an oil sketch by Piper, Best Wishes. An illegible signature was scribbled alongside the message. The postcard coined the title a lame parent would come to be known as The Chameleon Killer. Forensic psychiatrist Dr Barbara Kerwin later told the Telegraph newspaper that parent craved the attention of the authorities as much as she feared it.
画面显示她正从游泳池里爬出来。明信片的背面印着一条打字机打出的信息，上面写着：“你的变色龙，派珀的油画草图，祝好。”信息旁潦草地签着一个辨认不清的签名。这张明信片创造了这个称号，伊莱恩·帕伦特后来被称为“变色龙杀手”。法医精神病学家芭芭拉·克尔温博士后来告诉《每日电讯报》，帕伦特既渴望当局的关注，又对此感到恐惧。
The oil painting is very theatrical. I believe she sent it to law enforcement as a way of thumbing her nose at them, of sort of teasing them by saying, I'm alive, I'm well, look out for me, but you'll never find me. In February 1999, the case featured on the television show World's Most Wanted and it soon garnered international attention. Unconfirmed sightings of parent were reported across the world, in places like Turkey, France, Australia and South Africa.
这幅油画非常具有戏剧性。我相信她把它寄给执法部门，是为了向他们挑衅，可以说是嘲弄他们，仿佛在说：‘我还活着，我很好，注意我吧，但你们永远找不到我。’1999年2月，该案在电视节目《世界头号通缉犯》中播出，并很快引起了国际关注。世界各地都有人报告了未经证实的帕伦特目击事件，地点包括土耳其、法国、澳大利亚和南非。
The press dubbed the fugitive, The World's Most Wanted Woman. In April of 2001, St. Petersburg resident Patricia Nevins was preparing a special dinner to celebrate the Easter holiday. She headed out to a Sam's Club supermarket in the nearby town of Clearwater to purchase ingredients. The store was part of a member's only chain that required customers to register their details in order to shop there. As Patricia made her way through the store, she spotted a woman she recognized. It was her former roommate, a lame parent.
媒体给这位逃犯起了个绰号叫“世界上头号通缉女性”。2001年4月，圣彼得斯堡居民帕特里夏·内维斯正在准备一顿特殊的晚餐来庆祝复活节假期。她前往附近克利尔沃特镇的山姆会员店超市购买食材。这家商店是会员制连锁店的一部分，要求顾客注册详细信息才能在那里购物。当帕特里夏穿过商店时，她发现了一个她认出的女人。那是她的前室友，伊莱恩·帕伦特。
She had gained weight since Patricia had last seen her almost a decade earlier and her hair was longer and darker. Aware there was a global hunt underway for parent, Patricia's heart began to race. She drew closer to parent and for a moment, Patricia quickly looked away. When she turned back, parent was gone. Patricia reported the sighting and the supermarket's member database was examined for a lame parent's details. The information didn't exist and parent eluded investigators once again.
自从帕特里夏近十年前最后一次见到她以来，她长胖了，头发也更长更深了。意识到全球都在搜捕帕伦特，帕特里夏的心开始狂跳。她走近帕伦特，有一会儿，帕特里夏急忙把目光移开。当她转过身时，帕伦特已经不见了。帕特里夏报告了这次目击事件，并检查了超市的会员数据库以查找伊莱恩·帕伦特的详细信息。根本没有这条信息，帕伦特再次躲过了调查人员。
One year later, in April 2002, parent featured on another episode of America's Most Wanted. After the program aired, a number of calls were made to the show's tip line from Panama City in far northwest Florida. Multiple callers claimed that parent was living in Panama City's affluent neighborhood of St Andrew's Bay. They identified themselves as neighbors of hers and were able to provide her address. A representative from America's Most Wanted promptly informed authorities. Three police officers headed to the address. They arrived at a modest single-story house and knocked on the front door. A middle-aged brunette woman answered.
一年后的2002年4月，帕伦特出现在了《美国头号通缉犯》的另一集里。节目播出后，来自佛罗里达州西北部远郊巴拿马城的线索热线接到了许多电话。多名来电者声称帕伦特住在巴拿马城富裕的圣安德鲁斯湾社区。他们自称是她的邻居，并能够提供她的地址。《美国头号通缉犯》的一位代表迅速通知了当局。三名警察前往该地址。他们来到一栋简朴的单层房屋前，敲了敲前门。一个中年深色头发的女人应门。
She was dressed in silk beige-colored pajamas. The officers provided a cover story, telling the woman that they'd received a 911 call from the address and were following up to make sure everything was all right. The woman introduced herself as Darlene Thompson and provided a military ID that featured her headshot. She looked nothing like the photographs of a lame parent that the officers had seen. They thought that the tipsters might have been mistaken. She was asked to accompany them to the station for questioning anyway, just to be certain. Darlene agreed and asked if she could get changed first.
她穿着丝质米色睡衣。警官们编造了一个借口，告诉这个女人他们接到了该地址的911报警电话，并前来跟进以确保一切安好。这个女人自我介绍说叫达琳·汤普森，并出示了一张带有她大头照的军人身份证。她看起来一点也不像警官们见过的伊莱恩·帕伦特照片。他们认为提供线索的人可能搞错了。为了稳妥起见，她还是被要求随他们去局里接受询问。达琳同意了，并问她是否可以先换身衣服。
The three officers waited outside her bedroom as Darlene headed inside. While she was gone, one of the officers examined Darlene's ID more closely. P had a military background and was familiar with the appearance of their identification cards. Darlene's ID was missing a crucial stamp to verify its legitimacy. The officer knocked on Darlene's bedroom door to address the matter and she called out, I am getting dressed. Suddenly, a gunshot rang out. The officers raced into the bedroom and found Darlene lying in a pool of blood.
当达琳走进卧室时，三名警官在她的卧室外面等候。她离开后，其中一名警官仔细检查了达琳的身份证。P有军方背景，对他们的身份证件的外观很熟悉。达琳的身份证上缺少一个验证其合法性的关键印章。警官敲了敲达琳的卧室门来解决这个问题，她喊道：“我正在穿衣服。”突然，一声枪响传来。警官们冲进卧室，发现达琳倒在一泊血泊中。
There was a wound in her chest and a 357 magnum revolver in her hand. She died at the scene. Darlene's fingerprints were collected and on Monday, April 8, it was confirmed that she was indeed a lame parent. It emerged that the house where parent had been living belonged to another woman. Parent had been renting her spare bedroom since August 2001. Her roommate described her as somewhat hyper with a passion for cooking gourmet food. Parent had told her that she worked at a telecommunications company downtown. The roommate had a Pecanese poodle cross named Molly that parent walked twice a day.
她的胸部有一个伤口，手里握着一把.357马格。她在现场死亡。人们收集了达琳的指纹，4月8日星期一，证实她确实是伊莱恩·帕伦特。据透露，帕伦特一直居住的房子属于另一个女人。帕伦特自2001年8月起一直在租她的客房。她的室友形容她有点亢奋，对烹饪美食充满热情。帕伦特曾告诉她，她在市中心的一家电信公司工作。这位室友有一只北京犬和贵宾犬的混血名叫莫莉，帕伦特一天遛它两次。
She said parent would take the dog to nearby parks and chat to other women as she strolled. In contrast to this description, a neighbour told reporters that parent kept to her to herself and made no effort to be friendly. Quote, I would greet her and she acted like she wouldn't acknowledge me. I knocked on her door one time to warn her about a man wandering around offering to do people's yards and she wouldn't come to the door. A search of the St Andrews Bay house uncovered a counterfeit Florida driver's license with parents' photo but the name of the woman she was living with. Investigators also found a number of passport applications. Parents' closet was packed full of wigs and both men and women's clothing.
她说帕伦特会带着狗去附近的公园，在散步时与其他女人聊天。与这种描述相反，一位邻居告诉记者，帕伦特独来独往，没有表现出任何友好的意愿。引述：“我会跟她打招呼，但她表现得好像不认识我一样。我有一次敲她的门，提醒她注意一个在附近闲逛、主动提出帮别人打理院子的男人，但她就是不开门。”对圣安德鲁斯湾房屋的搜查发现了一张伪造的佛罗里达州驾照，上面有帕伦器的照片，但名字却是她同住的女人的名字。调查人员还发现了许多护照申请表。帕伦特的衣柜里塞满了假发以及男女服装。
There was a book on learning French and another about stage makeup. Some of parents' acquaintances mentioned that they often saw her working on a laptop but the device was never recovered. Nor was the diary that parent had in her possession when arrested more than a decade earlier as Charlotte Cowan in 1991. A notepad contained information about a man from the nearby city of Lynn Haven including his social security number and credit card details. A desktop computer contained data useful for making fake IDs. There was also an FBI Most Wanted poster that parent appeared to have crafted herself. It showed her passport photo with the name Antonia Rays Ormond. It noted that she was wanted for murdering a government official in a Washington DC hotel room.
有一本关于学习法语的书，还有一本关于舞台化妆的书。帕伦特的一些熟人提到，他们经常看到她在笔记本电脑上工作，但该设备从未被找到。十多年前（1991年）作为夏洛特·考恩被捕时帕伦特拥有的日记也没有找到。一个记事本包含有关附近林黑文市一名男子的信息，包括他的社会安全号和信用卡详细信息。一台台式电脑包含制作假身份证的有用数据。还有一张FBI通缉令，帕伦特似乎是自己制作的。它展示了她的护照照片，名字叫安东尼娅·雷斯·奥蒙德。上面指出她因在华盛顿特区的一家酒店房间里谋杀了一名政府官员而被通缉。
Panama City Police Commander Mitch Pitts later speculated that parent created the poster to intimidate someone. Many unanswered questions remained following the death of a lame parent. Law enforcement agencies believe she had up to 20 different identities that she used around the globe including the United States, the UK, Turkey, Israel, France and South Africa. Some suspect she murdered more than once, though no victims aside from Beverly McGowan have ever been named. Three years before parent's death, investigator Nora Pfeiffer told The Guardian, The brutality of the McGowan murder and the way in which the body was cut up leads me to think that a person capable of committing something like this has already done the same thing in the past or may do so in the future. A birth certificate for a lame parent has never been found, suggesting that a lame parent could have been another fake identity. Opinion has been divided as to whether parent worked alone or with an accomplice.
巴拿马城警察局长米奇·皮茨后来推测，帕伦特制作这张海报是为了恐吓某人。在伊莱恩·帕伦特死后，仍有许多未解之谜。执法机构认为她在全球范围内使用了多达20个不同的身份，包括美国、英国、土耳其、以色列、法国和南非。一些人怀疑她不止一次谋杀，尽管除了贝弗利·麦高恩之外，没有指认过其他受害者。在帕伦特死前三年，调查员诺拉·菲弗对《卫报》说：“麦高恩谋杀案的残忍程度以及碎尸并抛尸的方式让我认为，一个能够犯下这种事的人过去已经做过同样的事，或者未来也可能这样做。”伊莱恩·帕伦特的出生证明从未被找到，这表明伊莱恩·帕伦特可能是另一个虚假身份。关于帕伦特是独自作案还是有同伙，意见一直存在分歧。
Some speculated that parent could not have killed Beverly, then mutilated and disposed of her remains without help. Charlotte Cowan met a blonde man who parent had introduced as her brother. In the days after Beverly's murder, her credit card was used by an individual in a black wig and eyeglasses. Some witnesses described this person as male, while others thought they were female. Others were certain this individual, known initially as Sam, was a lame parent donning a disguise to look similar to Beverly. A number of investigators who have studied parents' actions don't believe she would ever collaborate with another person. Harvard psychologist Maria Conocova has written extensively about con artists and says that they commonly exhibit psychopathic and narcissistic traits. This analysis is consistent with forensic psychologist Dr Barbara Kerwin's profiling of parent.
有人推测，如果没有人帮忙，帕伦特不可能杀死贝弗利，然后肢解并处理掉她的遗体。夏洛特·考恩遇到过一个金发男子，帕伦特曾将他介绍为自己的弟弟。在贝弗利被谋杀后的几天里，她的信用卡被一个戴着黑色假发和眼镜的人使用。一些目击者将这个人描述为男性，而另一些人则认为她是女性。还有人确信这个人（最初被称为山姆）是戴着伪装以看起来像贝弗利的伊莱恩·帕伦特。一些研究过帕伦特行为的调查人员不相信她会与其他人合作。哈佛大学心理学家玛丽亚·科诺科娃就骗子写过大量文章，并表示他们通常表现出精神病态和自恋特征。这一分析与法医心理学家芭芭拉·克尔温博士对帕伦特的心理画像是一致的。
She has theorized that parents stole identities to, quote, fill up the emptiness of her own personality. She described parent as a consummate con artist, highly adept at reading her victims and targeting their individual and personal vulnerabilities. Elaine parents' living victims expressed relief upon hearing of her death. For almost two decades, her former partners, Witness X and Charlotte Cowan, lived in fear that parent would harm them. Investigators couldn't say why parent killed Beverly McGowan and none of her other known victims. In the documentary The World's Most Wanted Woman, Beverly's brother Steve explained that he carried guilt for cancelling her credit cards before her body was found. At the time, he believed that he was doing the right thing, thinking it would prompt his sister to reach out. Yet, he inadvertently cut off a viable means of tracking her killer.
她曾推测，帕伦特盗取身份是为了“填补她自己人格的空虚”。她将帕伦特描述为一个老练的骗子，极其擅长解读她的受害者并针对他们的个人脆弱性。伊莱恩·帕伦特的在世受害者在听到她的死讯时表达了如释重负的心情。近二十年来，她的前伴侣“证人X”和夏洛特·考恩一直生活在帕伦特会伤害他们的恐惧中。调查人员无法解释为什么帕伦特杀害了贝弗利·麦高恩以及她其他任何已知的受害者。在纪录片《世界上头号通缉女性》中，贝弗利的兄弟史蒂夫解释说，在她的尸体被发现之前取消她的信用卡让他感到内疚。当时，他认为自己做的是对的，以为这会促使他的妹妹主动联系。然而，他无意中切断了追踪她杀手的可行途径。
Occasionally, Steve's grief would overwhelm him. It could be brought on by minor things, such as hearing a particular song on the radio while driving his car. This sorrow and the lack of closure remained long after Beverly's murder, quote. It's been 11 years of wondering why. I mean, you do see stories in the newspaper and you read them and think, what a tragedy, but that would never happen to me. It could never happen to my life. And then it does. And boy, does it wake you up. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有时，史蒂夫的悲伤会压倒他。这可能是由一些小事引起的，比如在开车时听到收音机里的一首特定歌曲。这种悲伤和缺乏了结感在贝弗利谋杀案发生很久之后依然存在，引述：“这是充满疑惑的11年。我的意思是，你确实会在报纸上看到故事，你读了它们，心想，多么悲剧啊，但这永远不会发生在我身上。它绝不会降临到我的生活中。然后它发生了。天哪，它真的让你清醒了。”本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。